Hallöchen meine Süßen!
Heute gibt's eine richtig hübsche Erdbeertorte und das Ganze No Bake.
Im besten Falle haben wir nämlich gutes Wetter, die Erdbeersaison ist da und wir machen einen schnellen-
ja, eine schnelle Torte, die hübsch aussieht und lecker schmeckt!
Und dafür starte ich jetzt mit dem Boden, ich habe jetzt vorab Butterkekse genommen
- diesmal die Schoko-Variante, ihr könnt auch ganz normale Butterkekse nehmen -
und die einmal fein gemixt. Das Ganze könnt ihr auch in einem Gefrierbeutel machen mit einem Nudelholz,
Hauptsache sie werden schön fein. Und dann gebe ich geschmolzene Butter mit dazu
und das ist schon unser No Bake Boden. Und falls ihr euch fragt:
"Wo sind die ganz genauen Mengenangaben?", die sind immer...?
(H: In der Infobox!)
In der Infobox, genau!
(H: Man kann ja andere Kekse auch nehmen, ne?)
Genau!
Also auch generell andere Varianten, Haferkekse oder so.
(H: Also diese Standardkekse gehen auch.)
Diese Standard Butterkekse, ja das geht auch.
So, ich vermische das jetzt und dann geht's auch schon direkt weiter. So, ich hab hier nämlich was vorbereitet
Und zwar einen - ja, eine hübsche Tortenplatte, ich nehme jetzt gerne Rosa
und darauf gebe ich ganz einfach einen Tortenring. Wir brauchen hier keinen Boden, wir brauchen keine
Springform. Direkt da drüber geben und dann kommt unser Boden rein
und den drücken wir dann richtig schön fest an.
So, den Keksboden jetzt ganz kurz an die Seite geben und wir machen weiter mit der Creme.
Dafür habe ich hier Schlagsahne ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank hier in meiner Rührschüssel.
Die Rührschüssel ist ebenfalls kalt und der Schneebesenaufsatz ist auch kalt.
Wenn ihr das alles beachtet, dann kann euch nichts schief gehen! Jetzt schlage ich das erstmal ½min an,
geb dann nach und nach Sahnefest dazu bis es komplett steif ist,
das dauert so ungefähr 1min oder 1 ½.
So, die Sahne ist steif, die gebe ich ganz kurz an die Seite und jetzt geht es weiter in der nächsten Schüssel.
Und da habe ich jetzt Mascarpone drin und das süße ich jetzt mit Vanilleextrakt. Und ich finde Vanille
in Verbindung mit Zitrone ist mega geil, deswegen mach ich das jetzt so,
dass ich da noch einen Zitronenschalenabrieb rein gebe. Achtet darauf, dass es eine Bio Zitrone ist.
Den Saft brauchen wir nicht bei dem Rezept, also nur die Schale.
Anschließend kommt da Zucker rein und dann verrühren wir das nur ganz kurz.
Ihr dürft Mascarpone nicht zu lange verrühren weil das sonst Flüssigkeit verliert und deswegen nur ganz kurz.
So die lockere Creme ist jetzt fertig und die schmeckt echt mega gut!
Also wenn ihr jetzt schon nascht, dann probiert gerne mal, dann ist die Vorfreude größer!
So, jetzt gebe ich das bis zur Weiterverarbeitung in den Kühlschrank weil es ist schon recht warm hier.
Und in der Zwischenzeit werde ich die Erdbeeren schon mal dritteln und dann zeige ich euch die hübsche Deko!
Bis gleich!
So die Erdbeeren die kommen jetzt mit der Spitze nach oben in den Tortenring.
Das klebt wie von alleine, macht euch keine Sorgen!
Leicht andrücken und dann klappt das auf jeden Fall. So und jetzt gebe ich die restlichen Erdbeeren,
die ich eher in so sehr kleine Stücke geschnitten habe, einfach auf den Boden.
Da habt ihr die geballte Erdbeerladung, richtig lecker!
Und generell habe ich jetzt auch- also bis hierhin habe ich glaube ich nur 10min gebraucht, oder Hamza?
(H: Kommt hin, ja!)
Ungefähr ne? 10-12min.
So, dat ist jetzt hier alles schön auf dem Boden..
ich hab jetzt- ich muss aufpassen, ich leg grad meinen Ruhrpott-Slang ein!
Wat und dat! So!
Super! Sieht richtig gut aus schon mal. Und jetzt habe ich auch die Creme aus dem Kühlschrank genommen
und geb die einmal komplett drauf und dann schließen wir das Ganze mit...? Deine Idee?
(H: Kokosraspeln!)
Mit Kokosraspeln ab! Das war Hamza's Idee.
Ich hatte nämlich als ich die schonmal gemacht habe Kakaopulver genommen. Ich fand Kakaopulver
sah jetzt nicht so nice aus und Kokosraspeln passen besser.
Und so kommt jetzt die Erdbeertorte für 1h in den Kühlschrank, dann sitzt alles schön,
die Zuckerkristalle lösen sich auf, alles ist ein bisschen fester und trotzdem sehr sehr cremig.
Und anschließend fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich: "Wie entferne ich jetzt diesen Tortenring
ohne dass mir alles wegreißt und die Erdbeeren verrutschen?"
Da schnappt ihr euch ganz einfach den Backformlöser. Ich hab's immer Tortenringmesser genannt,
so kam's auch auf den Markt vor 20 Jahren aber im Endeffekt könnt ihr damit ja nicht nur Tortenringe lösen,
also Torten von Tortenringen sondern von allen möglichen Backformen. Der hat nämlich eine seeehr
dünne flexible Klinge und dann macht ihr euch auch nichts kaputt.
Und ganz am Ende gebe ich ganz minimalistisch nur noch eine Erdbeere oben drauf, die ich schön
gefächert habe und das Endergebnis ist für mich perfekt,
optisch und auch geschmacklich. Und euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen.
Ich quatsche jetzt gar nicht mehr darum herum, wir genießen das jetzt bei Sonne auf dem Balkon.
Und die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr natürlich in der Videobeschreibung,
hinterlasst diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben und abonniert natürlich meinen Kanal kostenlos
und dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten Mal wieder!
Keinen Fehler gemacht in der Endszene, whoo!
Tschüss!